بين بلد انجبه واخر احتضنه امضى ويليام
سيبولد اهم سنوات عمره في مكافحه نمو
النازيه وقتل حلم الامبراطوريه الالمانيه
الرايخ مظهرا ولا ان وانتماء للامريكان
حيث شعر بمواطنته الحقيقيه فما قصته ولد
ويليام سيبولد عام
1899 في مولهايم بالمانيا وامضى طفولته
هناك كما خدم في الجيش الالماني خلال
الحرب العالميه الاولى قبل ان يهاجر الى
الولايات المتحده ليعمل في تصنيع الطائرات
هناك ويحصل على الجنسيه الامريكيه في عام
1939 ذهب سيبولد الى المانيا لزياره
والدته في مولاي ولم يكن في حسبانه انه
مراقب من عملاء المخابرات الالمانيه الذين
طلبوا منه التجسس على مصانع الطائرات
الامريكيه وهددوه بكشف بعض الاوراق التي
لم يكن ذكرها بمعامله طلب التجنيس
الامريكيه لم يكن امام سيبولد الا ان
يوافق على عرضهم فقاموا بتدريبه على تمرير
الاتصالات والرسائل السريه بتقنيات
الراديو ومنحوه الاسم الرمزي اي الصعلوك
والاسم المستعار هاريسويا قبل مغادره
المانيا ذهب سيبولدي الى القنصليه
الامريكيه في كولونيا بالمانيا وابلغهم
بتعرضه للتهديد عارضا التعاون معهم ليتم
تجنيده كاول عميل مزدوج لامريكا في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه في الثامن من فبراير عام
1940 وفيما كانت اوروبا في حاله حرب عاد
سيبولد الى نيويورك على متن قارب بمهمه
شاقه وانشا مكتبا تحت غطاء انه مهندس ديزل
يقدم خدمات استشاريه فيما كان عليه تمرير
الرسائل بين المخابرات الالمانيه وعملائها
كما تم تجنيده الانضمام الى اكبر حلقه
تجسس المانيه هناك تحت اداره فريدريك
جوبردوكين في مدينه نيويورك كانت الحلقه
المكونه من 33 عضوا تجمع معلومات حول
سجلات الشحن الامريكيه البريطانيه
والتكنولوجيا العسكريه الامريكيه وتدعم
الالمان ضدهم لكن سيبولد تمكن من كشفها
واحباط اهدافها ففي الثامن والعشرين من
يونيو عام
1941 اعتقل مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
اعضائها وحكم على بالسجن لمده 18 عاما مما
اعتبر انجازا كبيرا للامريكان حيث انهوا
اكبر شبكه تجسس في تاريخ البلاد بعد انهاء
خدمته مع مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه تم
التحصين سيبولد ضمن برنامج حمايه الشهود
ونقل الى كاليفورنيا لكنه بسبب مخاوفه من
انتقام الفيرماخت اصيب بالاكتئاب
الهوسي ولزم مشفا علاجيا حتى وفاته عام